nehmen wir die spritze setzen die schräg
an skills und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem allerersten knochenmarkspende
wheelock und wir als geht rund heute
morgen habe ich mir schon die erste
spritze gesetzt
max hatte aber den navy so man sagen die
video einstellungen an der kamera
verändert deswegen weil die nicht mal
auf fischerei und das alles mehr scheiße
aus deswegen nehme ich ab und zu noch
mal für euch genau jetzt wollte war der
erste tag ich habe heute morgen die
zweite spritze gegeben ich gebe jeden
tag zwei spritzen morgens zwei abends 2
wir waren heute auf der interboot messe
in düsseldorf
also ich hab meinen vater und haben max
dann auf dem rückweg nach aus köln
abgeholt der war gestern
money boy getroffen was sich wegen
getroffen mit ungeteilten sorgen auf
jeden fall doch welche mitgliedern aber
anders programm namens ich mach das
jetzt noch vor euch genommen
ich erkläre das wie das ist ich will es
einmal so zu gestalten dass leute die
sie eventuell dafür interessieren sich
erwägen das zu machen auch so bis
informationen bekommen und ford auf der
folgendermaßen ich habe hier guck dich
zu sein
da zwei packages einmal 34 13 jeden
morgen und jeden abend gebe ich einmal
34 und einmal 13 und morgens und abends
im abstand von zwölf stunden so und
jetzt erklären wir das mal bzw
ich weiß wenn ich schon wie das geht
aber ich bekomme ich alles ich habe
diesen typ hier bekommen so sieht sie
aus
aber auch die desinfektionstücher dazu
versuchen wir hier zu platzieren
der kanada war perfekt mit fischer ist
es einfach so eine ganz andere sache
es ist auch immer besser im büro presse
aus ich weiß wir die packen gestimmt ich
weiß die packungen club so sieht es aus
wenn das einmal so eine er sein pulver
hier gefriert und pulver dann eine
spritze mit kochsalzlösung zwei kanülen
und wie das alles funktioniert ähnlich
jetzt und dann werdet ihr am ende des
videos auch sehen wie ich mir das alles
spritze junkie so als allererstes nimmt
man denen so das pulver agieren
zack bumm und erstmal hier die plastik
ab
das wurde kamper drauf sagt das sieht
dann so aus dass muss dass es infiziert
werden
warum humor unterschieden der anleitung
und deswegen wird's gemacht denn ich
will mir keinen empfang of the nation
bon mit dem desinfektionstücher die auch
mit gegeben sein
darüber sollte eigentlich reichen so wie
ich wunderbar krankenhaus und dann
nehmen wir diese kanäle die braune dann
kommt es einfach gar nicht drauf aber
jolo folgendermaßen wir das dringend
diesen grauen verstoßen
auf der spitze darauf ist dass aus gummi
aber nicht drehen sei einfach mal ziehen
und machen folgendes braune kanäle hier
drauf so sagt wohl und dann die konstanz
um hier rein zum pulver nach kommt
keiner motorische probleme ist alles
kein ding
so haben wir die lösung rein geballert
und jetzt schuldet mir dass ich glaube
ich zu keiner minute
die angelegenheit als jetzt aufgelöst
das folgendermaßen noch mal mit der
braunbär ahlen idealer weise das loch
was wir gerade im zugestochen haben ich
glaube ich nicht erwischt egal und jetzt
so die namen einsetzen dass wir das
absaugen können
guckt es nicht ganz drin ist der
finalort nicht ganz rein sondern davor
einen holen das den schritt raus hier
das gute zeug so dann ist das teil leer
und jetzt die braune ab und die gelbe
die zweite die auch dabei ist drauf die
gäbe es doch nicht so ein kaventsmann
sich die braune und die werde ich mir
recht geben
ich habe die vertauscht problem
na gut dann machen desinfiziere ich
jetzt die nicht eben verwendet habe das
ist nämlich die die man unter die haut
sie anderes deutlich größer das habe ich
denke ich bin verzückt
ich hoffe dass ich jemand also die gelbe
ist die richtige ich war ich wollte mir
jetzt ineinander neue königin nena ich
weiß nicht ob er genug dabei sind dass
sie also auch kein problem jetzt hier
das desinfizieren ich habe irgendwo
hingelegt aber nur um sicher zu gehen
sollten gut dann die hier drauf die
braune
ich kann schwer das ist heute morgen
anders davon entfallen 8 und 4 schon
geschlafen und war heute morgen
dementsprechend am morgen so sehen wir
kommen hier die dinge raus kommt die
luft raus komplett alle bläschen raus
sind
mehr keine luft natürlich fortsetzen und
jetzt mache das so im hier so eine falte
die kammer vorher auch noch
desinfizieren und dann zack bumm nämlich
plätze setzen die schräg an
ja
und jetzt
sorgt
langsam und gleichmäßig sich sind
darunter die auf kunden
wunderbar
alles klar
gut dann kann man das jetzt abschließend
nummer desinfizieren
ich glaube die desinfektionstücher
reichen nicht aus wieder dabei sind
jetzt hat man den unteren berger und
friedlichkeit rein gesetzt wurde ist
auch schon der ganze zauber das macht
man zweimal am tag sollte ich jetzt noch
eine zweite spritze aber das ist vom
prinzip her das gleiche frage ich euch
noch mal im zeitraffer rhein noch einmal
zusätzlich zu der 13 die ich mir jetzt
schon gesetzt habe noch die 34 er auch
diese zählt auch die andere seite gebaut
und diese aber richtig mit der richtigen
spritzen
ja das ist die sache und das jetzt für
die nächsten vier tage oder 17 17 18 19
20 uhr morgens zwei stürzen abend zwei
spitzen um 21 uhr morgens noch mal zwei
spritzen und dann geht's um 21 auch
schon zu spenden
ja so viel dass weiter ich werde euch
weiterhin mitnehmen und das ein bisschen
dokumentieren wie das für mich ist und
wie auch kanal und die nebenwirkungen
sich gestalten werden wir schauen mal ja
das war bisher das war's vom heutigen
blog ich hoffe dass es für euch auch
interessant ansonsten eher lassen daumen
nach oben da schreibt fragen die ihr
habt in die kommentare zu dem thema wir
sehen zum nächsten video wieder auf rein
macht's gut und
schau